في السودان وبينما تستمر المحادثات بين
وفدي الجيش السوداني وقوات الدعم السريع
في جده بواساطه سعوديه امريكيه لوقف
القتال يبدو ان التفاؤلا حذرا بات يلوح في
الافق على الرغم من الاشتباكات العنيفه
طبعا التي شهدتها العاصمه الخرطوم خلال
الساعات الماضيه الناطق باسم العمليه
السياسيه خالد عمر يوسف اكد على ايجابيه
الاجواء خلال مباحثات جد قائلا ان
المفاوضات تسير بشكل جيد وهناك اراده
للتواصل الاتفاق واشنطن عادت ولوحت بعصا
العقوبات على طرفي الصراع العسكريين في
السودان اذا لم يتوقف النزاع بينهما وجاء
ذلك على لسان وكيله وزاره الخارجيه
الامريكيه التي اكدت بانه رغم التفاؤل
بالمباحثات لكنهم يدرسون ايضا الاطراف
التي يمكن استهدافها بالعقوبات ما لم
يوافق الفصيله المتحاربان على ذلك ياتي
ذلك مشاهدينا فيما تتواصل التحذيرات
الدوليه من تدهور الاوضاع الامنيه والصحيه
والغذائيه بشكل خطير واتساع طبعا رقعه
القتال بين طرفي النزاع الى حرب شامله
فضلا طبعا عن تنامي اعداد اللاجئين
[موسيقى]
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات